do you know how dubai makes their money
the most common guess is likely oil and
given that they're surrounded by
oil-rich countries this is a fair guess
but it's not actually true
according to the cia 49.8 percent of
dubai's gdp comes from industry 49.2
percent comes from services and 0.9
percent come from agriculture
in other words oil production accounts
for less than one percent of their gdp
today
meanwhile saudi arabia is the exact
opposite
in saudi arabia the petroleum sector
accounts for 42 percent of their gdp 87
of their budget and 90 of their export
earnings and when you consider that
their flagship company saudi aramcoa
often posing over 100 billion in profit
per year their dependence on oil hasn't
exactly been a limiting factor
but as the world slowly transitions over
to renewable energy it's not the best
idea to continue this dependence and the
sauds are well aware of this this is the
main reason that they've been investing
so heavily into hospitality and tourism
over the past decade just like dubai for
example they spent 3.8 billion dollars
building a phenomenal airport they
started handing out tourist visas for
the first time in 2019 and most
iconically they've been trying to
dethrone the bridge khalifa with their
own skyscraper called the kingdom tower
yet despite their efforts none of these
plans have really led to much results
their multi-billion dollar airport often
looks like this and their kingdom tower
which started construction in april of
2013 it still looks like this clearly
saudi arabia has had quite a bit of
trouble completing these attractions and
attracting tourists so why is saudi
arabia failing to copy dubai
by far one of the biggest limiting
factors holding back saudi arabia is the
negative stigma surrounding the country
whether it's true or not the western
media has painted an extremely negative
picture when it comes to saudi arabia
from women and not even having simple
rights like driving or watching movies
to gay people being executed saudi
arabia has toned down a lot of their
stances and policies over the past
several years to become more open to
tourists but overall sentiment
surrounding saudi arabia hasn't really
changed according to tourists who have
traveled to saudi arabia the common
theme seems to be that if you're
respectful to their culture and you
don't push the boundaries you shouldn't
have any problems whatsoever
with that being said though when someone
is on vacation they don't necessarily
want to conform to guidelines like no
drinking so saudi arabia naturally falls
down their list of vacation destinations
something else to consider is that
people don't associate saudi arabia with
vacation in the first place dubai had to
work decades to create this association
and the primary way they accomplished
this was through their airlines we all
know about the fancy middle eastern
airlines and their lavish first class
residences but even the economy stating
that these airlines are the best in the
world and given that maximizing profit
is not a top priority for these airlines
they're able to offer extremely
competitive rates despite their superior
experience and over several years as
people traveled around the world for
work and vacation they started to
associate emirates etihad and qatar
airways with luxury and naturally this
image carried over into their respective
countries and cities as well if we're
being honest no westerner would know
about doha or abu dhabi if it wasn't for
qatar airways and etihad so clearly
these airlines played a massive role in
putting the cities on the global map
saudi arabia however does not have such
an airline the average person likely
doesn't even know what their airline is
called or what the capital of saudi
arabia is
and when you're trying to become a
tourist destination this is extremely
bad news
not only does the average person not
associate you with tourism but they
associate you with negative things
now this isn't to say that saudi arabia
is bad and that dubai is perfect because
the truth is dubai has a lot of the same
shortfalls as saudi arabia
for example i'm sure we've all heard
about saudi women trying to flee the
country but did you know that princess
latifah a daughter of the ruler of dubai
tried to flee the uae she accused her
father of holding her quote hostage and
she was captured and taken back to dubai
so clearly there's something going on
there too
but dubai's airline and hotel marketing
far outweigh such stories and in the end
that's all it comes down to marketing
dubai has brilliant marketing while
saudi arabia does not and as long as
that doesn't change saudi arabia will
struggle to replicate dubai success
as we can see saudi arabia
is having a hard time with branding but
this shouldn't stop them from making
internal progress right
for example successfully finishing the
kingdom tower has nothing to do with how
the world views saudi arabia
the success of this project solely
depends on factors that saudi arabia has
control over like budget engineering
talent construction workers etc yet
saudi arabia is struggling in this
sector as well so what went wrong well
the answer is that while saudi arabia
has control over these factors they
haven't managed them particularly well
starting with the budget the kingdom
tower was never really funded correctly
originally the tower was supposed to be
1 mile or 1600 meters tall
to put that in perspective the burj
khalifa is only about half that size
coming in at 829 meters given these
sky-high ambitions the estimate for the
building was also sky high coming in at
28.5 billion dollars while saudi arabia
initially approved this plan this proved
to be too much even for them
they eventually reduced their blueprints
to a kilometer hightower which was okay
but the problem was that they also
reduced the budget down to one point two
three billion dollars which is less than
the british colifis budget of 1.5
billion dollars
it's not that this can't be done but
trying to accomplish an engineering fee
and a financial fee at the same time
makes entire project magnitudes harder
aside from limited capital the kingdom
tower was also hammered by the 2017
saudi arabian perch if you all aren't
aware of this event it was basically
when the crown prince of saudi arabia
mohammed bin salman arrested the most
influential princes ministers and
businessmen in the country to apparently
crack down on corruption now these guys
weren't actually put in jail rather they
were put in a ritz culture hotel and
they were bored from leaving until they
paid a hefty fine and when i say hefty i
mean hundreds of millions if not
billions by the end of the purge saudi
arabia generated a mind-boggling 107
billion dollars clearly the purge was
extremely successful but the thing to
note is that a lot of the businessmen
who were arrested were the ones that
were responsible for building the
kingdom tower and shortly after they
were arrested in january of 2018 the
construction company would hold
construction on the kingdom tower
now the official reasoning is that this
company had labor issues with
contractors but honestly i think this
had more to do with the purge i mean if
you milk these businessmen out of 107
billion dollars it's not crazy to think
that they may be pissed off and that
they might hold construction in
retaliation more recent news suggests
that there has been movement around the
tower and that construction has resumed
but the purge literally added half a
decade onto the project here's a
side-by-side comparison of how the tower
looked in 2017 and how it looks in 2022
clearly not much progress was made
during this time frame and as the
construction it continues to drag on it
the primary question has transitioned
from whether saudi arabia can build a
tower to it if they should build a tower
the concept of skyscrapers was born out
of necessity cities with limited space
couldn't afford to build horizontally so
they built it vertically this gave
construction companies a new challenge
as they tried to build the tallest
strongest and the most practical towers
in the world but with mega projects like
the burj khalifa the shanghai tower the
one world trade center and the kingdom
tower the most important factor has
completely disappeared from the equation
practicality much of these buildings
aren't even occupiable for example 29 of
the burj khalifa is unoccupiable and 39
of the virgil arab is unoccupiable
in contrast less than one percent of the
empire state building is unoccupiable
aside from wasting so much space the
space that is used isn't even used that
efficiently b1m recently posted a
phenomenal video about how the buildings
on billionaires row are half empty the
billionaires who buy these properties
have little interest in actually living
there for them it's just a good place to
park some cash and it gives them some
pride so while these skyscrapers are
insane feats of engineering they serve
very little value to society and the
countries are starting to take notice
china for example is cracking down on
what they deem to be vanity projects
considering this the question becomes is
the kingdom tower even worth it for
saudi arabia let's say everything goes
perfectly for saudi arabia let's say
they're able to rebrand themselves and
that they finish a tower will tourists
just start flooding in
well i think the answer is not really i
mean that's exactly what doha did and
how many more people go to dubai versus
doha the truth is dubai was the city
that invented the desert kingdom image
and unless they screw up really badly
they're always going to be tourists top
choice simply building a taller tower or
a larger airport isn't going to take
that title away from dubai
not to mention it dubai is building
something called the creek tower which
is supposed to beat out the kingdom
tower so it's not clear how long saudi
arabia could even hold on to the title
of having the world's tallest tower in
other words saudi arabia can't just
build their way into replacing dubai
at the end of the day to really
understand why saudi arabia is
struggling to emulate dubai success we
have to think about why people even
travel in the first place they travel to
experience something new and unique and
to relax and have fun if riyadh is just
a copy of dubai what's new or unique
about it also you don't have to have
crazy architecture to attract loads of
tourists in fact most tourist
destinations don't have the architecture
or luxury that dubai does yet they
remain extremely attractive destinations
take tokyo for example their skyline
isn't anything particularly remarkable
but it's one of the most popular travel
destinations thanks to its rich culture
and food similarly why do people go to
singapore it's not because they have
crazy buildings it's once again because
of culture and food and i'm not sure why
saudi arabia doesn't embrace these
aspects more saudi arabia is literally
the center of islamic culture and
heritage now i'm not suggesting opening
up mecca to the public but they have so
many historical monuments and mosques
that you can't find it anywhere else why
not embrace what no one else has instead
of trying to become a soulless lavish
place like dubai this isn't to say that
saudi arabia should abandon the kingdom
tower i know this falls under the sunk
cost fallacy but they've already spent
so many resources and so much effort on
this tower that they might as well
finish it with that being said though i
don't think they should start any other
vanity projects instead i think the bulk
of their efforts should go into
embracing what makes them unique after
all 2.5 million pilgrims already travel
to saudi arabia every year why not
embrace their culture and make this tens
of millions
but that's just what i think would you
guys ever go to saudi arabia comment
that down below
also drop a like if you agree that
copying dubai is not the way to go and
of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you